hey what's up y'all super duper kyle
here check me out on the bootleg kev
podcast all right real rams fans only
yeah not me
welcome to the bootleg cab show we got a
special guest my guy kyle is here man
thank you kev thank you kev
yes shout out to kev man yeah so are we
back to independent now we're back to
independent bro which is how it all
started that's how it started that's yes
that's that's like
that's home for me you feel me
independent is like
that's comfortable that's how i know how
to operate best
yeah i feel like you know for people who
don't know you kind of like
there was like a cool wave of like guys
like yourself
uh there was the guy who looked like uh
he should be in like a 50s movie with
the glasses uh [ __ ] uh gorgeous
looking guy with the hair you would make
music about oh g eazy no no he kind of
he was kind of like a
the gz that didn't make it did you easy
that didn't make it
gorgeous looking guy from the 50s
oh you mean dui d-y yeah yeah and then
futuristic and like you know what dui
though is actually he's doing he's doing
this yeah he's doing some cool [ __ ] yeah
he's doing his thing dy dui but i just
remember like that was kind of like you
know like because i was real cool with
futuristic at the time and so like i
would kind of always see your [ __ ] and
his [ __ ] and but like independently you
kind of got it out the mud yeah um so
you know there's a lot been going on
with you man yeah yeah what brought you
back to uh kind of leaving the major
label system and getting back to what
you what you know best
um you know what for me it was like
when
when i when i partnered with you know a
major
it was a cool experience because it's
like damn you know you have this budget
for everything everything you're doing
is coming out at like the top tier
things but you start realizing pretty
quickly like
there's not much that they can do
for your music to
like explode at this this expectation
that they've set you right now you know
what i mean like really all of my set
success was
organic
as [ __ ] you feel me like
my marketing advice from people i was
working with was to do this
you know what i'm saying and it's like a
while you're getting paid for this and
there's no [ __ ] they're getting paid a
lot for that right you know and and you
gotta recoup whatever they're getting
paid exactly and so in and there's no
like shade to them at all because my
time working with atlantic was awesome
but i just realized i'm like oh
financially it makes way more sense for
me to just
do this thing myself because
that's all they're asking me to do
anyways just be you and hopefully some
pops off but if it doesn't pop off we're
gonna be like
uh disappointed you know what i'm saying
and now it's like
being independent i'm getting back to
just making music because i think it's
cool not because you're chasing i'm
chasing some sort of smash yeah and
especially for me the smash record they
want me to chase is like
a diamond song like yeah you know what i
mean like i cannot repeat
that success for you at the drop of a
dime and also i don't want to spend the
rest of my career trying to repeat that
for y'all you know what i mean and then
also like just all that goes into that
right like like in the major label
system they're going to force you into
the studio of people that you don't want
to be with nothing and then they're
going to maybe force a song to drop that
you might not feel crazy about but then
they put all this [ __ ] money behind
it and then you're like
well what what the [ __ ] like i gotta
[ __ ] that comes out of my [ __ ]
that's
to my balance yeah yeah one one that's
adding to my tab and then two
it's like really in me i'm like
i'm i'm really easy to work with like
i'm impressionable right like i'm nice
i'm easy going and i'm like flowing with
it and now i'm i'm noticing that like
the team i've built
you know is sort of pushing me in a
direction that it's not necessarily good
for me it's not healthy for me
you know like it's not healthy for me as
an artist like
i was
put here to make music and to like
honestly go against the grain it just so
happened at this one moment in time me
going against the grain became
the popular thing
but if you ask anybody who's ever worked
with me i'm always in the studio trying
to do whatever is most left that's just
how i operate right you know
and so when you have this whole building
behind you and it's like nah we going
left they're like no kyle [ __ ] go right
man go nah i can't
you know yeah no was it like because
when you have a record like i spy which
is like uh like you said it's diamond
it's not diamond but it's gonna be
diamonds it's like
seven crazy going eight times insane and
it streams like 250 million times a year
it's it's in it's like one of those
insane hit records anomalies and
was it like a curse and i mean obviously
you're going to love the money you're
going to love i mean
that should put a lot of money in your
pocket but like um is there a curse
that's the reason i can go independent i
never need to be with i probably never
need to be with a major again
because of that song you know it's
amazing and it's like that's
where my true joy is coming from me
being able to do art the way i want to
do it not because i
have to do it in order to make money
financial pillow exactly yeah but do you
think like just in terms of like
atlantic's perspective when that's like
your first i mean i guess kind of your
first record with them yeah
and it's like a diamond song yeah it
kind of like
the expectation now is like
exactly so it's like no matter what and
you're like yo i'm like an artist i do
like cool artistic [ __ ] yeah i'm like i
got here for a reason but now i'm
those guys are gonna have you be like
yeah well we got to follow this up
straight up and that's why i that's why
i don't like take anything away from
them and what they're trying to do i
think just for me
like the situation just no longer fits
what makes what brings me joy and that's
what life is about you feel me having as
much joy as possible until
you finally are no longer here and i
think
yeah it just didn't add up for bringing
me joy anymore because it's like y'all
one
you're like our idea for how to pop this
off it's just to me to shoot tic tocs
like i can do that on my own right
straight up yeah thanks to the advice
thank you for the advice then two it's
like
okay
yeah that that song that y'all want me
to follow up is like a once in a
generational song
like so i can't dedicate the next five
years of my career to just trying to put
that on the board i'm not gonna have fun
i need to be able to go just do [ __ ] i
want to do without feeling like i'm
letting you all down every time like i
said like now we going left [ __ ] kyle
please right nah i can't it felt like
there was a couple of records that you
dropped that like felt very uh forced
yeah you know and i
i agree the thing is with me i can kind
of make any kind of genre of music right
and that's not like trying to big myself
up too much it's just the truth you know
i mean like i can go in the studio with
any person from any background any
language anywhere in the world and i'm
gonna make a slap with you so
like
i'm always down to try some [ __ ] but i'm
realizing oh i'm trying this and y'all
are excited about it because you're just
thinking dollar signs and that's not how
art is supposed to be made you feel me
like quincy jones told me
and it's the truest thing the moment
you're in the studio and you start
thinking about money or you start
thinking about
financial success and that's what you're
talking about
god gets up and leaves and if god is not
in there making songs with you what
makes you think it's going to be hard
it's not everything that's fire in the
world is fire because god helped it be
lit like that
like
if he's not in the studio with you
making music it's not gonna slide and
the moment you start focusing on
money that shit's not gonna slap so it's
like yo
um yeah just some of those records i
felt like were uh we're doing this
because
i'm so nice and i'm trying to appease
this uh y'all just want another yeah
massive massive song and it's like i
can't i can't spend my time doing that
and it also like obviously the situation
was probably very beneficial because it
i mean when you're on a major
there is uh a notoriety that comes with
that there is a yeah you know
i feel more visible
yeah and like you know [ __ ] you
got into the acting game the netflix
movie was super dope yeah um
thank you thank you thank you i'm just
trying to remember then i just remember
you puked yeah it's after party after
party that [ __ ] was great yeah thanks it
was like realistic too yeah it was like
kind of like
it was like low-key like a little like
davish before dave yeah you know what it
felt very
like
almost like a biopic or something but
the only thing is it was really close to
my life but i think that was just the
stars of lining like the kids supposed
to be mixed that's one thing like his
dad's supposed to be in the marines
that's another thing it was like the
east coast version of my actual life you
know his manager being like this other
white dude that is his friend from where
he's from that's like nolan you know
what i mean it's like very
yeah it's like it's like the new york
version of me
um
the like i thought that movie was great
um
are you doing more of that like are you
gonna be doing more acting and stuff
like yeah yeah hell yeah i did um i was
i was lucky enough to be in this uh
russo brothers movie called cherry fire
starring uh yeah starring tom holland
michael gandolfini sierra bravo this
dude named forest
uh good luck [ __ ] spider-man's in it so
it's lit yeah oh i was having the
movie's already out i haven't seen it
yeah it's already out it came out on
apple and by the way thomas that's what
shout out to you cause who the [ __ ]
got my dog you're my dog shout out to
apple plus ted lasso's gasps yeah ted
lasso hey cherries guys i gotta check it
out my free my free uh
what was it the free trial ran out so i
was like all right well i knocked out
ted lasso
now i gotta sign up man i'm too busy
watching uh y'all get a fire stick and
just call it a day bro just go bro i got
over that [ __ ] cody trying to links
loading being all [ __ ] slow i'm like
dude i'm just gonna pay for everything
what am i doing you'd be like 30 minutes
into a [ __ ] bootleg link on your
hacked fire stick and the [ __ ] would
freeze you'd have to find a new link it
was now for sure pay for this [ __ ] man
just just pay for it kev you got it bro
kev you have it i got all right you got
it oh i i have every everything else so
i'm a [ __ ] paramount plus watching
apple float in yellowstone right now yo
kev when you get apple plus you watch
yellowstone i do stash it's gas it's
tight it's kind of like the real
it's kind of like the real like
cowboy version of succession that's all
it's succession with like guns and
more alcohol that's like beth dutton is
a [ __ ] gangster-ass [ __ ] she's lit
she's lit i was it was like it's like
sons of anarchy on on horses yeah yeah
yeah it gives me succession vibes dude
it does yes because of the family aspect
yeah i'm still a little touch of racism
in there it's kind of like successful
there's like
it's like it's like the salt bay like
just enough a little bit otherwise it's
a great show but let's yeah yeah
yeah it's a lot of white people in
montana they do got the one black guy
who's in the bunk house yeah you know
what the the thing is bro never says
[ __ ] i'm like yo he doesn't say [ __ ]
he's just there just like
we need we need we need a black guy like
diversity just give one black dude put
him in there don't have him say nothing
but i do love this shot at yellowstone i
love this show i think it's fine kevin
costner's from compton kevin costner is
from compton but kevin costner also is
from
ventura what yeah i didn't know that you
know growing up in ventura you like
everybody's like kevin costner he's like
the most he went to buena high school he
went to the high school that my fiance
went to
wow i actually met kevin costner before
like in in ventura yeah in ventura we
were doing like this ventera like little
um
i think it was like a benefit concert
and
all of a sudden this like kind of like
security guard type dude walks up and
it's like hey you know kevin costner is
like
here and i'm like oh [ __ ] kevin
costner's friend he's like yeah right
there like you can you can say hi to him
it's almost like a invitation to say
what's up but not like kevin coster
wants to say hi to you just just so you
know he's right there you can talk to
him like oh [ __ ] you know i'm kind of
nervous
i walk up i'm like yo uh
kev
i was like it's nice to meet you man i'm
probably like yeah i know you are he's
like yeah you're mr ventura now and i
like
wow i wanted to cry bro kevin costner
called me mr ventura you know it's crazy
not that that's like a title somebody
has but if anybody can give that title
out to somebody he's for sure him yeah
as much as like kevin costner's a legend
field of dreams dances with the wolves
if i meet kevin costner today i'm
calling him john dutton you can call him
john yeah but that's even more lit
because that means he's still like if if
somebody can look at you like this
can i get a photo straight up as an
actor if somebody can look at you and
call you your character's name like
your [ __ ] is smacking right then and
there in the moment you know what i mean
yeah yeah no uh it's crazy because i'm
on you know now i'm on the radio every
night in ventura shout out to q and
mambo and those guys and sir
um but i went and had lunch
like downtown ventura is a vibe it's a
yeah come on it's a big vibe waters
right there
yeah ventura is kind of like a special
place because it's very um it's like
anywhere
usa type vibe it's just very small it's
like the last small it's like the small
it's the only like small town
vibe you can catch in like southern
california to me that's like
really like special and feels like its
own place there's no place like ventura
and when it's like 25 minutes past
calabasas or something yeah exactly it's
here like it's really here but it's not
here it's its own world you know yeah no
it's it's um ventura is a vibe man like
i feel like a lot of people who like you
know my homie joey boy would always tell
people like yo man you gotta start
telling people to
like you know have weekend trips to
ventura like oh you know little
staycations and [ __ ] staycations wait
who's this joey boy he used to do boy he
used to be on the radio out there okay
joey boy stop stop giving up the secrets
bro
don't no one nobody going up there we
trying to keep this [ __ ] to ourselves
i'm sorry kev you can come only the
dallas cowboys are allowed yeah facts oh
yeah i used to watch the i used to watch
the cowboys
over there all the time like at practice
and whatnot i remember one time i walked
up to terrell owens to get like an
autographed ball and he kind of like
just like
gave me like a wave instead and i was
like wow [ __ ] you tio [ __ ] you bro did
you get anyone to sign that ball i got
mike van dijk
that sounds familiar but i'm not sure
exactly what he did mike manager was a
kicker for the cults that ruined
everything so oh
yeah yeah
not as cool as t.o but i tried what's up
y'all got to interrupt the bootleg cab
podcast we have a brand new sponsor
and i love this sponsor i've been giving
them my money for a long time it's about
time they gave some back my bookie yes
that's right
if you are a gambler if you're not a
gambler let me tell you my bookie is the
best place to go all right super bowl
season is here super bowl 56 is right
here and trust me my boogies double
deposit bonus is something you don't
want to miss if you sign up at my
booking now use the promo code bootleg
that's b-o-o-t-l-e-g
to have your first deposit matched
instantly
up to a thousand dollars so if you put a
thousand in they'll match your thousand
dollars and you get in on all the action
for super bowl 56 i mean seriously
joe burrow versus matthew stafford the
rams are playing the super bowl at home
in la what does that even mean because
none of these home games i've been to
them
it's a lot of out
outdoor fans coming in the 49ers but
took that place over twice in the last
month we'll see how the bengals fans
show up all right this is the most
important game of the year it's the
biggest game of the year and you can get
paid by watching it my book is giving
you everything you need to do it with
that double your money you can double
your winnings and the best starting
point for the big game is these super
bowl prop bets they're fun
anybody can do these right
hey mom what color do you think the
gatorade is going to be to get spilled
at the end of the game hey what about
that toy the coin flip is it heads or is
it tails whatever it is is matthew
stafford going to throw a stupid ass
interception probably
probably
is joe mixon going to score a touchdown
i like it i don't know get in on that
prop back action and uh listen even if
you don't pick on who's gonna win you
you could be a winner all right uh it's
a great look the prop bets are the most
fun for the super bowl so don't miss out
head to my bookie double your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars by
using the promo code bootleg
place your bets get ready for the
unmatched excitement for that super bowl
that is a thousand dollars in free money
that they will match so you deposit a
thousand they match a thousand bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
let's get back to the podcast
so you didn't grow up so i'm a very
optimistic kid okay so you grew up a
rams fan though i grew up a rams fan
yeah which is interesting because most
people in la or in this southern
california region obviously there are og
rams fans because rams used to be in l.a
for a period of time shout out eric
dickerson but yeah but if you're one of
them rams fans like you can't
you must have gray hair to claim yes
like straight yes or like a bunch of
tattoos and like yeah i'm like i know ah
these guys this guy's been there yeah
but then but but i've been to a lot of
rams games this year and i feel like i
call them rams bros yeah
rams bros yeah because they're like you
know they've lived here for like six
years they're in santa monica or venice
yeah yeah yeah they kick it at bungalow
or whatever that one club
there's a football game bro la's got a
team
[ __ ] rhymes let's go yeah there's a
lot of those for sure and then there's
yg
who was a 49er fan yeah there's a lot
see this thing about this thing about
the 49er thing right
um
it's like there's a lot of especially
people my age
like what the [ __ ] else were you
supposed to root for that entire time no
for sure luckily enough
my family is from st louis my mom my dad
like when i was a little kid we were
watching the rams especially because
when i was a little kid they were lit
kurt
straight up bro marshall fog isaiah
bruce like
oh that we were killing it so i was
watching all this [ __ ]
but all my homies were all niner fans or
cowboy fans which is well yeah because i
can imagine in like in the 805 it's a
lot of cowboys fans hella cowboy fans
and raiders fans cowboys fans are the
most delusional fans in all sports
straight up they don't they don't
realize how much they suck they're crazy
they're crazy i actually am not even mad
at the cowboys their fans [ __ ] suck
yeah no their fans are trash their fans
treat it like they're on a dynasty run
right now and it's like no y'all are not
yeah you're really not um
so are you obviously you're feeling good
about the super bowl yeah of course
you're going to be there have you spent
38 000 on a ticket [ __ ] no because yo i
have season tickets for the rams yeah
and i looked up like my seat i get my
seats at like face value right you know
what i mean
and i looked up my seat and that [ __ ] is
39 000 a piece oh i got two of them
and i looked at my i was like baby we
we're not going
i'm sorry yo if you know some other dude
that just got got in like you might want
to hit him up because we're not going
yeah no uh it's crazy because if even if
i could like you know obviously if you
have season tickets you're not getting
super bowl tickets but i'm selling if i
have [ __ ] rams tickets i got them at
face value for some reason i'm slanging
them things yeah well they don't give
you that option
right i would have loved to sell my [ __ ]
for 38 thousand and not go
first when you have season tickets you
don't have access to the super bowl
tickets
that's true yeah you see how cold that
is you don't get access to the super man
rams i love you all but
i have a problem okay it's backwards yo
so talk about the new album uh give me
the meaning behind the title got you
it's not so bad um
yeah my new album was basically like
it's just a word of affirmation it's not
so bad is like something i tell myself
a lot because in the middle of that
pandemic it was like damn life really
sucked
at least from i know for everybody but
like from my own personal experience
like
i was really really
hating
hating life i just dropped see you when
i'm famous it's like in the middle of
the pandemic i can't go to where i can
to go do [ __ ] for it right right right
it's like just a lot of wack things at
once but
i'm truly an optimist and i believe like
at any given moment you can either see
the world as a [ __ ] up place or you
can see it as a beautiful thing if you
pay attention to
small things in your life that are
actually meaningful and that's why i was
just telling myself i'm like dude it's
not so bad like it's not so bad there's
a bun like i'm in this situation with
this label that i don't like you know
like
it's like i can't promote myself or do
anything in the middle of the pandemic i
don't know what to do but i started
focusing on things that just
genuinely brought me joy and i started
realizing how much i don't need
this situation with this label how much
i don't need
all this promotion and
you know and and this tours these
festivals and these things i thought
were completing my life so much
it's like no i need to like make music
and have fun and i need to remind people
that
all they need is joy right and so that
was that was the meaning behind the
title it's just a word of affirmation
that was helping me
and then with that
when i started making the album
it was like this lo-fi album
in like it was sad [ __ ] it was like
beats to study too i was for real
interesting
music i just throw that [ __ ] on there's
like like one where like homer's driving
dude yeah yeah yeah so
but i'm in there with like top tier
producers like playing like low five
beats like yeah we about to do this [ __ ]
that has like two sounds in it they're
looking at me like no we're not you know
but i was really i was really like on
that
and then i realized like bro that's not
the superhero version of yourself that
you claim to be you know like you claim
to be somebody who's gonna help somebody
forget about their worries and about
their [ __ ] and like look on the brighter
side so don't you dare drop this sad ass
album in the middle of all this sad ass
[ __ ] bro
and so i went up i left la i went to
miami
because la just was like so sad at the
time like we really took kovit not that
we took it serious because we should all
take it serious but we kind of took it
overboard yeah a little bit you know a
little bit we took it a little overboard
and miami was kind of
doing the complete opposite
i went to miami i was like this is
amazing yeah me too it's like yeah i
feel like i feel like life is normal
again right straight up life was normal
out there and it just was like kind of
like an escape for me and i went out
there
and i made as much turn happy
music as i could and i did it in an
environment where i had 15 people in the
studio which i never do
right and that's why when i hear this
album i'll go out to the club or
something like that which i never
[ __ ] do right anyways but then i'll
go out there and i'll hear it played
with all this other exciting music and
it fits right in for the first time you
know because a lot of my music is always
so personal and so just me by myself
this [ __ ] is vibing because i did it
with like 15 people in the studio like
hey what's up y'all i'm kyle i don't
know none of y'all but i need to have a
really good time right now because life
[ __ ] sucks back home
let's make an album and that's
sort of how we did it you know that's
how uh i've been in the studio with game
a few times the last month and um
it's a lot of [ __ ] people in there
man
rappers be operating like no no i've
been to a lot of sessions over the years
i mean maybe thousands not a thousand
maybe a thousand yeah maybe like 500 but
have you been to thousands of sessions i
mean you know like
i have a couple artists i work for a
week but like uh
the game had like a legitimate like
50 60 people in the studio and i i
wanted to guess i was gonna be like it
was a lot bro yeah and like maybe like
five of them were actually contributing
to like the music yeah
people hitting hookah [ __ ] drinking
like i'm like this [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy
it's like playhouse in here yeah the
[ __ ] is going on but see there's a pat
look for me like i always thought that
that [ __ ] was weird but i thought i
think it adds like for him like wherever
he is creatively right now like that's
like the that nah but it is juice though
it helps because like yeah like for me
like i always thought that she was weird
i'm like how the [ __ ] can you all focus
about like telling like this really
personal story in front of all these
people and that's the key though like
when you have other people in there and
music is loud on two big ass speakers
everything you're doing is impacting
their mood so if you turn around and you
see these 60 people all just [ __ ]
chilling on their phone like
you know if their vibe is [ __ ] up
that's because the music you're making
is not geared for entertaining large
amounts of people at once you know so
it's like a cheat code kind of
in a way like you need to have other
people in there and and you captivate
their vibe like my fiance she's a dj
right
and uh the homie that nr this project uh
just demi is a dj
and so i have them set up in the lobby
right with two big ass speakers
and mixers now y'all are going dj in the
lobby and so when people walk in to the
studio yes when people walk in keaton is
making them a drink right
every 60 minutes everybody in the studio
needs to take a shot this is a rule
if you're not taking this shot you're
leaving you know what i mean unless for
whatever reason you don't drink it's
part of your religion some [ __ ] like
that but
we're gonna take the shot right because
we're making party music we're making
music to help people forget about their
problems so
if you don't want to be in here where
the studio is at what we're making in
the lobby there's loud ass music and
you're taking a shot out there too so
everybody is entering this sort of zone
of like
this is a party you know
side note
i wish it was kind of the soundcloud
days because you could just throw this
the lo-fi album out just just just to
see just like yo let's
i mean the album is there i could put it
out like i just i mean you're
independent now right i can literally do
that hardcore like fans are going to be
in the comments like oh we want to hear
the [ __ ] lo-fi album man be like i
i'll give it to y'all it's sad yes but
you know yeah yeah um art do you feel
like now that like you know because when
you were independent the industry was
way different right like um
it would be fair to say that you built a
lot of your following on youtube right
straight up yeah yeah um
but like just in general you know back
then it was you could still purchase
stuff on itunes
um their streaming wasn't as big and
what that was like what 2013 like 2014
yeah 2012. um
being independent now that the industry
has changed so much is like are you
having to still kind of i mean you know
the music industry you have very smart
people around you but like what are the
things that you're practicing now to try
to kind of
um repeat the success that you had you
know back then that's a really good
question i think um
the the industry has changed big time i
think back in the day it was about like
brand personality on youtube right
because youtube is a video yeah of this
guy do we think this guy's cool what's
his story what's he look like where's he
from you know like you capture all these
things because everybody's so heavily on
youtube and now in the streaming era
it's kind of more like all right does
this sound out of these 50 000 songs i
listen to
does it capture me and so i think the
name of the game now is really
focusing on your micro fan base right
your fan base
yeah your fan base is this my fan base
is this like i'm a very famous person
like when i walk yeah your monthly
listeners are [ __ ] huge when i walk
down the street like people are going to
recognize me type [ __ ] now visually
you're also very unique people are like
oh it's the guy with the great hair and
yeah i saw my necklace yeah that's what
i'm talking about yo
so it's here and then but i can't focus
on this in today's world right i have to
focus on this
this smaller amount of people that are
really into everything i do i'm engaged
engaged i need to super serve them
they're buying merch they're they're
buying everything they're keeping things
afloat i need to super serve them and as
i'm super serving them something will
raise its hand and then appeal to all
these people that's how you do it and
that's kind of what i notice in today's
independent game it's because the music
is easy to make the music don't cost
nothing to make you know so it's about
dropping as
much quality product as you can to these
people who [ __ ] with you and then if
something breaks out of that awesome
then you're on yeah yeah but those
people are gonna keep your lights on
they're gonna
exaggerate the bills i would tell every
artist that i'm like yo if you got a
core [ __ ] fan base like
feed them what they want
and then something's gonna break through
exactly if you're independent like it
only makes sense like you know at the
end of the day the name of the game is
to
support yourself
off of music straight up support
yourself off of songs and in the
streaming world that's what you do you
upload the song and it immediately
starts paying you in the youtube world
where i came from it's like no you build
as big of a brand as you can and you go
on tour and that's what pays you music
didn't pay nobody right you know so now
it's it's like and these people love you
they'll listen to everything so give
them as much as possible and and tap in
with them like i'm on patreon i'm on
twitch i'm on patreon discord i'm on all
that [ __ ] because these people me and
them we are friends i haven't heard of
many artists on patreon so kind of
because obviously in the podcast space
it's a lot of podcast creators that go
on patreon it's kind of like
only fans but without [ __ ] and tits
exactly yeah it's the only fans without
being hyper sexualized right so like if
you you know like uh if you have a dope
podcast you might
some people will have be on patreon and
they might do a bonus episode or they
might have like you might get the
episode before everyone else type [ __ ]
how do you use it so what i do is i just
give them the music first
if i have a song that's coming out next
month they have it right now you know
like
not for nothing and i know this is going
to piss people off
they had the album like a day and a half
in advance the whole thing every song
mastered the whole [ __ ] and i gave it to
them first i'm not getting none of them
plays recorded i'm not none of that you
know those streams aren't counting for
anything except for their excitement and
their enjoyment so i try to give them as
much [ __ ] as possible first and you're
monetizing that probably at a better
rate than your monetizing streams
damn yeah straight up yeah like yeah
[ __ ] the streams like you these people
are pay how much how much you charge
your money five dollars a month yeah is
there different tiers or just one
there's different tiers so what's the
highest tier i believe the highest tier
is
15
i think
and it just comes with higher levels of
access you know more [ __ ] i can give you
before i can give it to anybody else
that's big getting enough people doing
that there's you know you get enough
people doing that and once again you
don't have to worry about taking no
advance from nobody you know being in
some shitty lone situation
and really really what it was for me too
is realizing oh i'm massively successful
in music right like
i spy is a billion something stream song
you know maybe going towards two or some
[ __ ] like that
you know playing with me has like almost
500 million streams like hey julie is
another gold or platinum record like
there's massive success
but in order for me to be truly like
rich as [ __ ]
i need to be doing all that [ __ ]
independently by myself
you know it's real that's how you
actually reach like masterpiece status
or somebody like that who's genuinely
wealthy off their music you need to just
do it yourself and in today's world i
have these people who are supporting me
who love me my homies right this is my
family we're gonna keep things afloat no
matter what whether i'm up down sideways
and then i have all this endless amount
of music that i can release without
having to go through all this yellow
tape
i can just drop record after record
after record and when something waves
its hand to the masses cool if it
doesn't all of the money exactly
exactly and all i gotta do is make tick
tocks honestly because i can imagine
like okay so hey we gotta stop the
podcast man real quick appreciate y'all
for watching uh really mean mean it
subscribe like leave a comment even if
you're one of those [ __ ] who leaves
a comment yo why you always interrupting
the guests cause it's my [ __ ] podcast
i don't know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssocksofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview atlantic records like we
just saw i mean there's been a lot of
people
just not even atlantic but just
specifically like the major
label game is like
there's a reason why companies like
empire are thriving and you know some of
these distro companies that offer label
services because they're giving you like
a serious
like [ __ ] you got more of the chunk of
the pie than anyone than them and that
that's how it should be that's and and i
would say too sorry i'll just finish
i would say too i'm not anti
like company you know what i mean i'm
anti-royalty shares and master ownings
being so in favor of this company for
you to essentially still do all the work
yeah because there's people who like you
know if you do a major label deal and
they give you 13 of your album that's
like amazing that's like whoa people are
like oh you're killing it but but that's
like not even the norm like some people
like
they'll be lucky to get eight points on
their own [ __ ] which is crazy if you get
smacked like that i would
you now you're pulling up to the office
ready
what are we doing well you know like yg
just talked about it on lebron [ __ ] um
he was on the bronze hbo show and he was
saying how
he's never made he's never gotten a
check off his royalties yet like his
whole career it's crazy it's just
advanced advanced fantasy advanced man
and that's cap because
that [ __ ] is crazy bro because when i
think about somebody like yg like me
being from southern california has been
a literal staple in my like young adult
life since i was like 15. for sure right
since i was a child like we wanted to
dress like yg listen to yg be like yg
for somebody to be that successful for
so long and still never gotten a royalty
thing like
it's [ __ ] so ridiculous because as
rich as he is
he's had to have made them
ten times what's just that
it's that advanced thing right it's like
okay if i turn into album i get you know
whatever you worked out individually you
know so it's like some people i i don't
know i think i think like
the industry is starting to smarten up
artists are starting to realize like
i know some people who will just pass on
the advance and be like no i'm good like
you know let's do the service yeah yeah
yeah no it's crazy so that's dope so are
you just doing straight tune core
straight distro kit or nah so we're
doing so
i'm like still uploading yeah uploading
things through like distrokid and stuff
like that but still i'm working with
a company that's really just my managers
and it's independent and they're they're
my managers yeah and they're pitching to
spotify and pitching to playlists and
[ __ ] like that and that's all we're
doing that's dope that and then all the
same services that like a major company
was
doing or hiring out i'm just going to
those people because you know solo in
hiring them myself right i'm hiring the
press team hiring the digital marketing
team like there's still a team around
yeah but
there's no reason why you can't pay for
it for yourself also
hello not even a major label can
guarantee you a spot on a [ __ ]
playlist all they can do is [ __ ]
pitch it as well now they might these
people might listen a little bit you
know well they listen way stronger i'll
say that i'll say dude
even me putting this album out i'm like
oh y'all are listening way stronger
tonight like like i said i think
all companies i think that they're
awesome i just think that and what they
do is awesome i just think that the
business needs to be way more in favor
of the artist because so much of the job
is way more on the shoulder of the
artist all of it is on you i gotta go on
instagram and make this [ __ ] you gotta
be [ __ ] on tick-tock you gotta be you
gotta do everything and then they're
just gonna come through with a canister
of gasoline and then once you have the
fire once you have the firebase you got
to start the fire yourself exactly so
when i was like if i could start to fire
myself my gym i need some more of this
money exactly and if i start to fire
myself
i'll just go [ __ ] with somebody else and
just be like oh look i got this fire now
put some gasoline on it for this this is
what i'm offering you a fraction of the
thing to put the gasoline on it and
let's make it make sense but you got to
get out of that first situation to even
have the power to do that you know i'm
really not anti-company i'm anti-the
business of how much they're
taking on it was it easy for you to
break away like did you just fulfill
your contractual obligations or did you
ask to leave i have to leave and it's
and
it's and it was it was easy to break
away because like i said the people
there
like i'm like we have a good
relationship like i love them they love
me and it was always easy to work it was
never like static like i never had like
let me book the label moment i never did
that because they're people they're
people doing their jobs you know right
that's it they're really just people
doing their jobs just the the business
of it wasn't right so i'm like yo you
know and by the way my song was so
massive that
my [ __ ] advance checks are crazy
so
do y'all really want to do you want me
to turn another album in you want me to
tell me another album and you cut me
this fat ass check like what do you want
to do you know what i mean because
and i was also kind of like
making lo-fi music at the time yeah like
probably like like look y'all want this
album or what yeah nah nah we don't
actually and it's cool because i kind of
want to move on too so it's like it's
love you know it was good it was it was
actually really seamless really easy
that's dope man yeah well the albums
i've heard horror stories are you doing
anything else um that you could talk
about coming up yeah bro i mean first of
all yeah album is out it's the hottest
album of the year okay it's just this i
mean it is january what's february it's
february so far we got the hottest album
um and
yeah i'm going on tour for this album
and the tour starts in
march so are you excited to get back on
the road [ __ ] yeah i'm excited to i'm
excited to just
see the people
and i haven't done that in so long and
like as you noted from like 2012 is kind
of when i started my independent grind
that whole time was just supported by
like
10 people
30 people 100 people
400 people a thousand people 5 000
people 40 000 people at a show who are
connecting like and your live show is
dope as [ __ ] like i think the first well
i feel like i might have saw you at
south by i think we first i don't know
when we first met it was like 2012 or
2013. i think it was south by
but there was a when you opened up for g
on uh which tour was that that was the
uh
you had like inflatables
uh
these things happened to her and i had
these uh big-ass palm trees
yeah on the boogie board yeah you came
out on the boogie board yeah yeah yep
yep so yeah it's just i mean congrats
the tours march march how many dates uh
i think it's like 30 dates oh [ __ ] you
out here bro come on man man yeah it's
been a while because it's what been at
least two and a half three years since
you've been on the road three yeah at
this point it's been three and a half
years since i've been on the road which
is kind of like
a [ __ ]
time vortex portal you know it's almost
like my career i'm doing i have like a
career i'm doing my thing it's like
going in covet happens and you
fast forward three it's like three years
up and disappeared do you know do you
find it easier now because like you're
someone who came up with a cult
following
um
i feel like sometimes when
you have as much success as you have
with a record
it's easy to kind of deviate away from
like those people you were talking about
yeah did you feel like uh i've seen it
happen with a lot of artists right like
um i won't say names but you know people
who just had huge records and but they
kind of came up a certain way did you
feel like it was a little bit harder for
you to kind of super serve your like og
hardcore like f fans yeah you know what
it's like this is a perfect analogy it's
like imagine you throw a party
right and you're all there and it's a
party and everybody loves it we have
this we have this kyle superduper gang
party going on and just those people are
there
and then somebody leaks the address
and then 20 000 [ __ ] show up
and then you and now all these people
are in the party and you have to pour
all of them drinks and like it seems
like to your core fan base like oh maybe
he doesn't care about us as much because
when they come to the kyle concert now
now the same way he said the rams bros
are coming to the rams game when they're
there and now they're shoulder to
shoulder with the kyle bro that's just
[ __ ] going crazy i spy exactly so
i think that
it's not that it was hard to super serve
them i mean well it was because there's
yellow tape i gotta go through with the
records i'm releasing and all this [ __ ]
so i think it was a little hard harder
to connect with them
just them
but that's what's so great about the
place i'm in right now i feel like i'm
back to like
hey what's up y'all oh my god that was a
blair covid all that [ __ ] like
i love y'all and i love you guys for
letting me just make music and be me
i'm so ready to do that with y'all again
you know what i mean that's dope well
there it is man appreciate you pulling
up go get go go check out the album
check out the album it's not so bad i
it's out right now tom holland a nice
guy tom holland is that's my homie
shouts out tom he is the coolest that
that's like your peeps huh that's my dog
yeah he's great like everyone hanging
out with him and zendaya at the same
time you know what i actually only
kicked it with zendaya once it was at
his it was at his uh
he had like a it was like a movie
after it was like a really really tiny
little gathering
um
but i got like super lit so nice i i
think i embarrassed myself actually i
think i like tried to get on a table and
perform i spy or some [ __ ] it was yo you
guys want me to do i spy cause i'm here
yeah do it hey i'm here by the way y'all
know the song right yeah you all know
the song yeah i was like smash so
yeah but now he's great every time i'm
in london he shows me a good time and
like i ran into zendaya at a best buy in
atlanta no way yeah she was in line in
front of me and she had this really tiny
little white security guard but he
looked like he's a murderer yeah that's
that real that's how you know you're
cracking your security guard look like a
normal bro but i was like uh i was like
i just finished like euphoria uh and i
was like hey i'm a [ __ ] with you like
yeah they should give you a [ __ ] emmy
for that [ __ ] you know she was oh thank
you thank you i was like all right we'll
go buy your hard drive yeah yeah
there it is man shout out to the homie
kyle go check the album out do that cash
show boom let's go fire